first of all do we look amazing because
this is the most important interview of
my career
yes okay we're gonna begin first of all
I'm gonna say it again you're a winner
baby oh my god congratulations
I feel like mahogany in the Kabuki
finale yes this is the greatest show on
television and everyone knows that and
I've been saying that for years I'm
probably the biggest fan and people that
spend like me that spend a lot of time
sorry let me spend a lot of time alone
on airplanes and you like live this like
solo life and you can just click on
iTunes and like watch an episode
it like brings happiness to the world
yeah and I feel like that's what 2018 is
all about so what an amazing symbol to
take the Emmy home to it really is and
it's been a long time coming you know
our show really is it's entertaining it
shows all these wild antics from
outsiders but at the core of it it's
about the tenacity of the human spirit
and how you can overcome any adversity
adversity that you that you face and and
that's what it's about
I love that and so what do you guys
think you because you already got one of
these at home and you have one - I do
yes so I'm just adding another one to
your bin sure yeah bookends
you know balance is so important a
couple of things crazy have happened
tonight number one Glenn Weiss got
engaged on stage were you in the
audience tell me what happened well I
actually I proposed to Michelle visage
right after so I thought you know what
ten seasons yeah but I've been working
in the show for about 22 years yeah so I
think the engagement is longer I think
I'm gonna say what America's thinking
well I heard a rumor that cher is
possibly wanting to appear on drag race
what is happening with that she's been
doing press in Europe for her new album
and so uh someone asked her and she said
I think that's gonna be that's gonna
happen show so then it's going to happen
it's but so it is written so it shall be
good
episode that goes by where we don't
mention her or say now according to
Wikipedia 1993 is the year that you
broke out into the Hollywood scene so
we're celebrating with this Emmy 25
years of RuPaul what does this mean to
you because this show has been on the
air many seasons you have been working
in Hollywood for all these years and to
have the height of your career almost at
this point 25 years and I know it is
amazing I feel so blessed and I think it
has really to do with staying you know
interested in colors and music and
beauty and love and that's what it's all
about beauty colours music laughing
dancing and that's why I get up and in
the morning every day and go to work
this is the first year ever that a
reality show one in this category and
the hosts one two so you've just broken
easy I I'm just now hearing that for the
first time I didn't realize that I'm so
gobsmacked by the this show and how it's
touched people and how it really does
help young people navigate their lives
they've watch our Queens just we're just
circle around and crush obstacles and it
is life changing and I'm so proud to get
these awards and I'm so happy that the
Academy is saying well done I see that
you're the closest to the Emmy so does
this mean when you get back for the next
season when you're up at the what do you
call the desk panel will this be next to
you or I mean it really is me
yes well Michelle has Jim Golden Globes
already
[Music]
you